our both Paul Brothers single now are
you dating anyone Internet always wants
to know yeah yeah no I'm single I'm
single right now well that was fast
because it seems like Logan Paul has
found himself a new romance with Josie
Canseco mind you that interview was last
week and four days later he was snapped
at a flea market in Los Angeles
hand-in-hand with Josie yeah check out
this pic both dressed very casually
strolling around in baseball caps their
fingers totally interlocked and if you
want to know what they purchased well a
chastity belts phonograph and some
vintage skis interesting this in the
decade I feel I feel really good I feel
really optimistic I'm single I'm single
right now now when I was with Logan
literally last week not only did he say
he was single but he also revealed he
had made a list of qualities he was
looking for in a girl on his phone and
he read all of them off twenty twenties
a year the girlfriend yeah I'm confident
settle down I think so
wow this is a big moment what are you
looking for for all the viewers out
there I'll tell you who I'm I am in a
list these are these are qualities I
look for in in a girlfriend he's lying
no I swear to god it really is a little
girlfriend qualities when do you oddest
21st 2019 which was in my training camp
you know a training camp you have a lot
of time to do nothing alright so this is
for my future wife just like try to
check as many of these boxes as you can
girlfriend qualities wit confidence
intelligence opinionated empathetic
self-aware active listener sexual
deviant she got me a sexual deviant tell
me you don't want your wife to be
stifled Evie come on guy
talented worldly she's gotta have
foresight and she got to be insightful
well here's to hoping yeah here's to
hope when you find love and happiness in
2020 yeah of course Josie was last
linked to Brody Jenner
any birthday that relationship ended in
the fall ads for Logan he famously dated
Chloe Bennet for a while I mean we're a
couple in outer space so not know all
right guys what do we think are things
between Logan and Josie serious just a
fling let me know and for all the latest
on this couple and your other favorite
couples stick with all things et until
next time i'm katie Krauss and bye for
now
[Music]